and overseas many popular tourist
destinations are eerily quiet due to
coronavirus concerns the waterways of
Venice are largely empty and the Louvre
in Paris is closed today as more
infections are confirmed across Europe
more than 89 thousand cases have now
been confirmed in 66 different countries
with more than 3,000 deaths reported
Kris Van Cleave is at Washington's
Reagan National Airport for us Chris
good morning so how does the virus
affecting travel well good morning we
know the airlines are very concerned and
we got another sign of just how
concerned they were over the weekend in
an email from United's CEO where not
only are they worried as this virus
spreads that it's going to impact their
bottom line but it also could disrupt
their ability to operate flights around
the world now in this email to employees
sent over the weekend Oscar muñoz said
in addition to suspending flights to
China and scaling back service to
countries in Asia it is likely
additional scheduled reductions will be
necessary that could include parts of
Europe even domestic service also over
the weekend Delta and American Airlines
both announced they'll temporarily
suspend flights to and from Milan Italy
that comes as the State Department
raised its travel advisory for two
regions in northern Italy to level four
that's its highest level urging
Americans not to travel there the CDC is
telling people to avoid non-essential
travel to China Italy South Korea and of
course Iran Alaska American and JetBlue
are waiving change fees for fliers out
of concerns for coronavirus now the
virus is having a steep impact on demand
for travel take Italy in just a five-day
period last week searches for round-trip
travel to Italy dropped by 13% to the
lowest point of the year United has
already said it's seen demand for travel
to Asia drop more than 75 percent Gael
all right Chris thank you